[Music]
we're white against krasnodar c okay
let's go e4
and
i'd like to remind everyone that we have
been playing the four nights scotch with
tremendous success in the speedrun
and nobody as of yet has responded to it
properly so d6 that's a new move that's
one we haven't faced before
okay so it's sort of like a delayed
philidor and just like in the philidor
it makes sense to to play d4
okay so a transposition to the philidor
okay very passive for black
and already we're much better
well not much better but
better queen f6 so this is
i'm glad our opponent is playing like
this because i think some people have a
hard time responding to this type of
play including me against jasper
basically white has two approaches here
one approach is to
not decline the queen trade but to trade
on your own terms and play bishop e3
not so not so bad the other approach is
well we don't want to take because that
allows black to develop their knight
the other approach that we could take
is to decline the queen trade but if we
decline it we want to find the right
square
uh to put our queen on not just like
some random square
so
the
concept that i'm
you know that's germinating in my mind
here is the castle queenside to
try to quickly castle queenside and
punish black for not developing his
pieces
so
in the name of
in the name of castling queenside one
thing that we would want to do
is keep the f2 pawn protected although
we can obviously sacrifice it but
nonetheless there's a square for the
queen that i i'm quite confident is not
going to be intuitive to most people
it's going to look a little bit awkward
this square
but the queen is kind of overseeing
everything on that square yeah it's
queen e3
queen e3 then bishop d2 and castle's
queen side and what i want to really
indicate here all that we can also
fianchetto
but
let's play it simple here
yeah the bishop isn't great but our
primary goal right now is to castle as
quickly as possible
the
surface level problems like the bishop
they will resolve themselves we will be
able to improve the position of the
bishop so i always like to talk about
this like what is
temporary and what is permanent right
now
the most important thing is to castle
because if we can get our pieces out
really quickly we might have we might
have a chance to punish black for not
developing
and
you know and these temporary issues like
developing the bishop to a non-ideal
square are so much less important
i don't know if that made sense but
okay so let's castle
and now how do we wanna
well b6 our opponent is totally
unconcerned how do we want to conduct
the initiative here well there's a very
typical move there's actually several
moves we can try to exploit
the drawback of b6
by going bishop a6 sticking it on to
that weak square
and trying to go bishop b7 and win this
pawn
in fact that's probably the best move
let's do it
but the general approach here is to go
for okay bishop c8 wow
um
we have so many options here
we have so many options here
and all of them are good
we can take on c8 and go f4 and revert
back to our old strategy
we can again try to trade on our own
terms and shift the queen over to d3 for
example
or
we can play very romantically
let's play romantically let's see how it
turns out
actually no no it's it's premature
okay you guys i i can tell you guys want
me to sack
so i'm going to sack
but not in the way that i think people
think i will suck
i want to play
an interesting move this is not a move i
normally want to go in the speed play in
the speed on bishop b5
our opponent might think it's a mouse
slip
or maybe not
it has a very simple point though
the point is we want to stick our knight
on d5 and that will jump start the
attack
the point is we want to stick our knight
on d5 and force the queen back to d8
and then blast the center open
with the move e5 and i'm just judging
that our tremendous peace coordination
uh combined with the fact that black
doesn't have a single piece developed is
going to give us enough compensation
okay bishop b7
so our opponent declines it
but doesn't stop our main idea
so your instinct in such situations
should always be to ask whether you can
still play
the move that you wanted to play and in
this case you can because the pawn is
actually pinned sounds weird but it is
pinned this bishop is pinning the pawn
which means the knight d5 is very much
possible
and okay our opponent wants to keep our
bishop alive
be my guest
it's not really a sack anymore i mean
this is untouchable the queen is hanging
knight c7 is sort of a threat although
we might not even play knight c7 okay
what do we do now
and this move if you have any experience
attacking should come
totally automatically
this move should come with your eyes
closed yeah e5
classic
method of
of tearing the center apart
and and that's it the game is over i
mean black is just so overwhelmed here
by
you know a thousand orders of magnitude
here so queen takes c5 obviously
we might not end up sacrificing anything
here
97 ooh
oh man we have so many good moves here i
mean we can go knight c7 this is like
the utilitarian method of winning
knight c7 check and then forcing the
king to d7 and moving our bishop
but um
we probably want to win more in style
let me think about this for a second
don't get this opportunity too often
well probably the nicest
the most elegant move that's also quiet
is bishop g5 get this bishop out of the
way
set up a discovery
f6 okay
this hinges on black
playing
uh so we're gonna play queen e6
no we're not that's bad because of cb
no unfortunately i just don't see this
working out um
i saw a really really cool concept
after queen e6 fg like a genuinely cool
move that i'll show you afterward
but
let's not
go overboard and just go knight c7 check
i'll show you this idea after the game
and i'll show you how i know about this
idea okay well obviously we take the
queen we're up a queen the game is over
and the bishop is saying i mean
everything
yeah simplest is to take the bishop here
don't forget to just take material
sometimes just taking
material is the best approach
now i the first thing i see is that the
queen and the rook are making contact so
if we can pin this knight will threaten
queen takes c8 i think most people here
would be inclined to drop the bishop
back but moves like rookie one
you know as a 1700 you got to be able to
play
[Music]
um
yeah and queen takes c8
that's it
king f7 queen e6 okay black resigns
yeah slight difference between these two
games our opponent did not play well but
still
so let's start from the end because this
will just take me a second to find
so the cool idea that i had was starting
with queen e6 right
unfortunately black has c takes b5
and here i didn't see anything
convincing because
you might be thinking wait isn't doesn't
knight f6 win the queen but something i
frequently mentioned
whenever you give up a bunch of pieces
to get the queen you have to count them
because sometimes you've given up a lot
more than you realize and here black has
two
a rook and two pieces for the queen it's
it's not that clear
white is out of attacking pieces
but
i was really hoping for f takes g5 and
if i've calculated it correctly there is
a beautiful
winning move here
yeah maybe not even that convincing but
um
still
we should we should at least try to find
it it's
what makes it beautiful is the fact that
it's so quiet it's unbelievably quiet
and let me see if i can track down the
game that inspired me
yes i i have it
let me show you the game that inspired
me to come up with this move
i i don't think brandon sees it actually
it's it's honestly a
cool it really is a cool idea
so here is let me set up on chess space
the
source position
and i've shown this position to a bunch
of people it's not actually that well
known so it's tall versus nn tall versus
unknown
and so it's all was playing somebody
whose identity is not known
and the following position was reached
and this is highly complex i could talk
about this forever
i'll prepare for a
quick summary of
this position rather than
a long lecture
and n is unknown
and then is unknown so it's tall it's
tall against nn
so it's all starts with a pretty simple
combination if you have any experience
with these types of structures you'll
know that this particular section of the
pawn chain is quite vulnerable and so
tall plays knight f7
okay it's a very obvious tactical shot
because it loosens the six spawn
king f7
queen e6 check and king f8 and this is
the critical position
now looking at this for a couple of
seconds you might come to the conclusion
that rook f3 they i don't think the year
is known rook f3 check looks like it's
mate
it's a simul game
which makes it even more impressive that
paul found this move
and this looks like mate knight f6 queen
f7
okay bishop f6 is forced
and now
we hit a brick wall because you might
say oh rook takes f6 is winning
again knight f6 there's mate gf there's
like bowdoin's mate
but unfortunately there's queen takes f6
and there's a problem because white's
queen is also hanging
and white's going to end up down at
least a piece at the end of the at the
end of the exchanges takes takes okay
you can take g7 it doesn't matter
white is down a piece
so rook f3 doesn't work
rook f3 doesn't work
you might say okay let's solve the
problem by first taking the knight
also doesn't work because after bishop
takes d5 you can no longer give rook f3
check because now the bishop controls
that square
so you could say okay what if we take
the bishop first
knight e7 there's mate but now there's
rookie 7.
now rook f3 check there's no bishop to
cover with but now there's the e8 escape
square
dammit queen g8 king d7 black is escaped
and is up a piece still
so
why i don't know if random knows this
position or knows this move
so a lot of people
that i've given this to after some
thought
they they do recommend bishop h6
but bishop h6 is kind of useless i i
think black can just take
rook f3 there's still bishop f6 you
don't need the pawn i get you know
bishop d5 the queen is hang
and here it's all plays an absolutely
jaw-dropping move
so i'll give you guys a second to think
about it if somebody suggested i'll be
pretty i'll be very impressed
it's an unbelievable move it's not queen
h6 i can take the queen
yeah jasmine got it bishop c1
bishop c1
i don't know if jose knew this position
it's an unbelievable move
oh he was strolling
it is bishop c1
so the idea is incredibly pure
if you imagine the position after rook
f3 bishop f6
this diagonal is actually what's
weakened by bishop f6 so you would love
for if this bishop landed on a3 it would
be mate
so you prepare for that by playing
bishop c1 and it turns out that there's
absolutely nothing black can do
against the threat of rook f3 because
black is so tied down
and if you move the bishop here then a
bishop a3 check happens
it's so it's literally over immediately
um
well
black found a way to prolong the game
so for instance let's say queen d7 right
rook f3 bishop f6 bishop a3 check and
black
maybe isn't mated immediately but loses
all of his pieces
uh as you can as you can understand
in the game it's the computer best but
yeah this is the only move this is the
only winning move
black played
bishop f6 bishop a3 rookie seven
tall played
rookie four probably unnecessary but
this just shows you how paralyzed black
is king e8 bishop takes c7 97 d5
bishop b5 and now tall wins in style d6
bishop takes
d3 can you guys find the mate made in
two
yes d7
queen d7 queen g8 mate
beautiful
pretty stunning i the year i don't think
is known
um
so this is
i mean yeah bishops you want to find an
assignment is everyday i mean it just
takes a genius mind
like you i wish his brain could be
examined
yeah bishop c1
just to think of the concept that like
you have to reroute the bishop in this
position is unbelievable
um
so how does this relate you might ask
to our discussion of the uses of irony
it's
an obscure reference i don't think
anybody's going to get
so in this position
it's not exactly the same
and i don't think it quite works but
what move
did i come up
was i going to play here
bishop e2
and the idea is to play bishop h5 check
force g6 and then mate with knight f6
and if black takes cd then not bishop h5
because now after g6 there's no
follow-up but now the bishop goes back
to b5 and wins everything
because of the pin
so
any move basically you go
whatever any move you go bishop h5
knight f6
now black i i'm afraid has a defense
here
how can black defend against bishop h5
this is a kind of move that people very
often miss
yeah black can himself
play h5
and although this weakens the g6 square
it's being protected by the night now
i'm sure white is winning here
and maybe there is even a pretty win
let's see let's check with the computer
here
this is greatly the beauty of this is
greatly
diminished by by how winning it is to
begin with there's a hundred thousand
winning moves completely unnecessary
yeah so you can see by the way cb is far
less convincing
it's winning
oh wow rook he won
oh what a move this threatens bishop oh
that is really nice
this threatens bishop h5 and rook
queen g6 oh my god look at this mate
takes takes
now queen g6 there's king d7 so knight
c7
and queen g oh
okay that is bringing out of this world
that is so cool
and and this all happens because black
played h5 weakening the g6 square so
bishop b2 is not best because of
queen takes d5 but it is completely
winning
yeah and it's just yeah rook he won what
a move just so quiet
getting the pieces in place for this
combination
yeah
queen g6
i mean also wins but
yeah
g497
and here again queen g6
i mean is anyone not nerding out at this
if you're not then you're
you're in the wrong stream
it really is art i mean it honestly is
you show this to somebody who doesn't
think chess is art
anyways um
again
all of this is so unnecessary because
knight c7 check in this position was by
far the most convincing move
but nonetheless um it's better than
nothing so in terms of the game itself
in terms of the game itself um okay
queen e3 is good actually
you can see the evolves already
overwhelming and we played basically
correctly to castle quickly
knight d5 here was also very strong now
bishop b5
is
yeah not bad it it keeps a very
overwhelming evaluation actually
um but yeah the idea of this move was
knight d5 and then e5 and just you blast
everything open
although computer doesn't like it
because of bishop e6
according to the engine you have to play
knight takes b5 actually
a little counter-intuitive
uh and then just go for the bishop b4
sorry bishop takes this is that makes
sense
that makes sense you just go after the
d6 pawn instead
where did my opponent go wrong um in the
very open like just
everything
first of all d6 is passive
second of all knight d4 is just bad
and i'm honestly surprised that these
1700s are still doing it they they're
they keep going to these types of
positions with black where black is
incredibly passive and we're already
developing all of our pieces
so
i don't know why this instinct to take
on d4 but here black should play knight
f6 and black's position is totally fine
but anyways bye everybody thanks again
[Music]
you